When I did petri dish mold testing in my bathroom, one thing it showed was high candida.
My husband and I don't have any symptoms of this.
Should we test or treat ourselves for candida?
So this person is talking about using a company called Immutal Linux lab,
where you put these little petri dishes in different parts of your house.
I'm testing for do I have molds growing in my house that I need to deal with.
It's a good thing for everybody to do, you know, at least once in their home,
because you could have hidden mold behind the wall.
And you can't see it, you know, you can't smell it.
And you could be exposed to mycotoxins because of those things.
Now, if you do have that, you should remediate that area.
So you should clean that area with recommendations that this company may give you,
searching for different ways to decrease that candida, in this case, whatever mold is present.
Should you treat your your body for candida if you had candida exposure?
No, I wouldn't say so.
I have no symptoms of candida and you know, never did.
Should I treat my body for candida?
I would say no, I would not.
Just because you're exposed to something doesn't mean that it is a problem.
Now, if you did a mycotoxin test, a mycotox test is not going to test for candida,
because candida is a living organism, but it's a yeast that's not.
So a mycotoxin is a toxin that different molds give off.
It's not the mold itself.
So a mycotox test is not testing for living organisms in my body,
living molds in my body, living yeast in my body.
A mycotox test is testing for the toxins that those living things can give off that you then
can breathe in. So in this case, no, I would treat for that unless you had symptoms.
There's different tests that you could do to see if you have candida, but I wouldn't,
you could spend anybody on those labs if I didn't have the symptoms.